welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and I'm Legit
terrified for Ant-Man look man at least
the Scarlet Witch and Doctor Strange
appear to work out roughly the same
amount King's ABS have abs and despite
hearing from he who remains himself just
how terrifying his variants can be in
Loki season 1. I know for a fact that I
still can't fully comprehend just how
powerful he's actually going to be on
screen this dude is supposed to make
Thanos look like a goddamn squish mellow
in comparison so today I'm going to take
you through the comics to look at what
Kang and his variance powers are and
explain how we might see his Tech and
abilities in action in quantumania
technically King doesn't have any
traditional superpowers he can't
shape-shift or fly or turn a dude into
yarn spaghetti just by looking at him
nah man hang strongest power is that big
bad brain of his if you thought Tony
Stark was smart meet the guy who has all
the time in the Multiverse past present
and future to invent advanced technology
form expansive armies and strategize
recapping all of Kang's burien's
identities and their timelines would
truly take take several videos to
untangle so here's the extremely
Abridged version of what you need to
know about his Origins before walking
into quantumania born in the 30th
century is a possible descendant of Reed
Richards aka Mr Fantastic Nathaniel
Richards original reality was teeming
with technological advancement having
never experienced the Dark Ages he
discovered an ancient time machine
developed by his ancestors and was able
to reverse engineer it allowing him to
travel back to ancient Egypt there he
established himself as the Pharaoh Rama
tet who if you recall we saw a little
shout out to in Moonlight after being
ousted By the Fantastic Four ramatet
eventually made his way to the 40th
Century where he found its current
inhabitants at War unskillfully using
weapons from the past that they had no
idea how to operate ramitet realized
that he could use his Advanced knowledge
of these weapons from his adventures
through time to conquer this future
civilization and thus became king the
Conqueror with all his timeline
manipulating Antics Kang essentially
became a paradox stained into the time
stream spawning countless variants
within his own Multiverse in the
quantumania trailer we've seen Scott
split into multiple versions of himself
so I'm wondering if Kang weaponizes this
science to proliferate the meanest
baddest version of himself across the
Multiverse you know what time it is Bam
it's geology time geology is a 16-time
award-winning personalized skincare
company recognized in hypey's birdie
Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews and now they offer products for
whatever you need just take a quick 30
second diagnostic quiz and geology
figures out your whole routine for you
geology creates simple and effective
skin care and Hair Care routines
customized just for you with ingredients
that are proven to work no matter what
you're trying to take care of for Hair
Care use geology's co-wash a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses hair without the
harsh ingredients of typical shampoo
geology also has body washes that are
free of harsh ingredients smell great
and are refillable for skin care geology
can protect your skin from environmental
stresses with vitamin C and Eve acrylic
serum keep your skin looking young and
healthy and then a bit of dermatologist
tested aluminum free deodorant right now
for a limited time geology is hooking
our viewers up with an absolutely
Bonkers offer if you use code rockstar70
they'll give you an additional 70 off of
their award-winning skincare trial set
we did the math and that's five products
for just 15 on top of that you can take
an additional 30 bonus offer on one of
their brand new skin hair and body
products of your choice when you add it
to your trial to get started just click
the link in the description not all
Kings have the same powers in Tech but
between a lot of them they're capable of
pretty much anything some Kings can fly
like Iron Man While others utilize
hoverboards and chairs we actually see
Kang stepping off this hoverboard here
in the trailer the strongest of Kings
have the combined knowledge of each of
their variants throughout time and space
and can travel the Multiverse without
creating Divergent timelines nearly
every King can theoretically access Tech
from any world at any point in time this
is how Kang's able to create a suit that
mimics superhuman abilities you know how
Sylvia was able to stab he who remains
in the gut like a low blonde ghost face
that variant wasn't decked out in the
same armor that's going to be
responsible for squashing Ant-Man like a
bug made of a rare scent Ally from the
40th Century his suit has the ability to
neuro connect to his thoughts AKA if
King's subconscious thinks it up his
suit makes it happen he's able to lift
up to five tons and has an attached
anti-gravity device that allows him to
render heavy objects weightless his
armor has a defense Shield capable of
withstanding a nuclear blast at
point-blank range can block telepathic
interference and is equipped with a
self-contained survival kit that
includes a 30-day food supply a Waste
Disposal system and even his own
surrounding atmosphere he even has Tech
that can disappear objects into Subspace
allowing him to redirect projectiles
like Thor's hammer on top of all this
his time manipulation Tech allows him to
alter the fabric of time space with ease
much like how hisahi who remains Dodge
Loki and Sylvie's attacks in the Loki
season 1 finale his ultimate method of
survival however is his suit's ability
to transfer his Consciousness into a new
body at the moment of death ensuring
that even if you somehow make it through
any of these other obstacles he'd still
Outlast you and then there's the
Weaponry by cracking his fingers Kane
can summon any weapon from any place and
any time period throughout the time
stream instantly he's used everything
from neutrino Ray Warhead missiles to
nerve gas spray and not only can you
summon weapons he can even pull forth
dinosaurs or other time displaced beings
hang also has dutiful Androids called
growing man stimuloids that use alien
poem that functions kind of like pen
particles if that wasn't enough he can
also deliver electric shocks through his
fingertips and can activate a powerful
electric burst simply by flexing his
muscles bro this guy can literally Fry
Paul Rudd with a single sit-up and my
guess is that the scariest moment from
the quantumania trailer is employing
this Tech at one point in the comics
hang also had access to the heart of
forever aka the forever Crystal which
many are theorizing might be the
MacGuffin of quantumania this powerful
energy source is capable of altering
history without creating Divergent
timelines additionally it can erase
people and things from a timeline's
reality completely much like the
timeline pruning we saw the tvas use in
Loki if this speculation is true and
Kang needs Ant-Man to pull Heist for the
forever Crystal it's clear that we'll be
introduced to a King who either hasn't
yet achieved his full power or has had
his power reduced in some way likely by
the party responsible for trapping him
in the quantum realm so what's the power
level we can expect to see in
quantumania well by nature of sporting
his green and purple armor I think that
we'll see some enhanced strength and
durability as well as some futuristic
Tech that allows him to unleash energy
blasts in his Flying Saucer we also see
that he has a small army of robots and
battleships at his disposal my guess
though is that this King will have
limited time manipulation powers without
the MacGuffin he's trapped in the
quantum realm so it's unlikely that he
can just summon whatever he wishes from
the multiverses time stream we could
possibly be looking at a king who can't
even alter temporal events at the start
of the film meaning that his deal with
Ant-Man could not only free him from the
quantum realm but also power him up to
the Godlike level he is in the comics
and based on comments from director
Peyton Reed that this variant of Kang is
quote unquote conserving his energy it's
likely that his true show of powers
won't be visible from the very beginning
like I said though there are definitely
some duplicating shenanigans that Kane
can make use of within the quantum realm
and he clearly has the power to unravel
reality and the hordes of Ant-Man at
some point in the film but this might be
limited to the climax with all that in
mind I actually feel a little bit better
about Scott going up against Kang I mean
he's still gonna get his ass handed to
him but maybe he won't be completely
erased from reality in the process
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
whitneypuppy falling Rockstar subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
foreign
[Music]